times change
you do what you gotta do think it's most
employers don't want mothers it's a
competitive market you don't know me
for money
you survived
now might be the time so what feel 24
months left on her services sorry baby
this is diverse mom organized crime
we're gonna take care of you you girls
gonna be just forward we got no money
can't even make the rent with what they
gave me last night they didn't want me
in the family in the first place 40
years they pay protection and we don't
get nothing for it
they have been telling us forever that
we are never gonna do anything but have
babies bunch of men that they forgot and
what family means so we remind them no
pretty mama pretty doesn't man was just
a tool women use what anything we want
what do you want we're gonna have crews
everywhere can see you got brains and I
know you got money but we got one thing
that you don't
criminals so you can't go around was it
for a bunch of women you're not smarter
than me I will wipe you off the face of
the earth
I don't want you to talk
and I want you to teach me how to it
just to be clear now we run this
neighborhood
step off my business baby my business
left they're gonna swallow this entire
city you go to war
there's no coming back also karate wants
to talk if we go to Portland we're dead
what are you where does something like
that get dressed up thank you
[Music]
my god I lost count again
[Music]
you